The Witcher 3 is out very soon and part
of the reason for the series success is
thanks to the engaging narrative take it
from Andrei slipped off skis novels now
that's not vyas example but here are 5
other games who've decided to take a
leaf out of someone's book that was
cheesy but I'm sticking with it backups
the line may not have had the best
shooting mechanics but it did have a
really cool story inspired by heart of
darkness Joseph Conrad's novella from
1899 the story of spec ops the line
follows Captain Martin Walker's journey
to do by now desolate and enveloped in
stand and his attempt to uncover what
happened to Colonel John Conrad it turns
the shooter genre on its head in a
really clever way and the story is just
littered with twists and exploration
into the human psyche a lot of these
concepts are taken from heart of
darkness which I've personally found to
be a bit of a slog but it must have been
good because it also inspired the film
Apocalypse Now as well as far cry 2
another novel with more adaptations than
you can shake a pocket watch at is Lewis
Carroll's Alice in Wonderland from 1865
a personally my favorite of those is
American McGee's Alice the events of
American McGee's Alice take place after
those written by Lewis Carroll although
in the video game [ __ ] seems to have hit
the fan in a big way Alice accidentally
burned a house down and her family along
with it was committed to a mental asylum
and fell into a delirium where her mind
now resides in a grim and twisted
version of Wonderland American McGee
expanded upon the darker themes present
in Carol's original story in a big way
and it works so well from the
reimagining of the now skeletal Cheshire
cat to the delightfully stubborn and
headstrong attitude of Alice in both
versions
despite her very different circumstances
dark post apocalyptic novels do seem
like they'd make pretty good videogames
and in the case of Metro 2033 the source
material was so good that they decided
to stick pretty damn close to it the
novel of the same name written by Dmitry
Glukhovsky takes place in
post-apocalyptic Moscow the story
follows Artyom Adair born into the world
of dank subway tunnels who goes on an
adventure traversing the hostile
irradiated world and it's threatening
inhabitants Metro 2033 was originally
released online where it became kind of
an interactive experiment budding
authors from all around the world would
write their own stories based in the
Metro universe featuring different
characters and genres all of which were
a hundred percent supported by the
author eventually for a games decided to
put their own spin on the universe by
turning Artyom story into a hardcore
first-person shooter helping the world
of Metro reach new heights of popularity
like Alice sometimes the game can serve
as a direct sequel to a book such was
the case with hideous sinners parasite
eve the book is all about evil
mitochondria taking over people and
animals until they become monsters
there's also a Czech called Eve made up
of said evil mitochondria who makes
people explode if they get too close to
and you have to kill her off before she
has a scary monster baby hell-bent on
human annihilation it's all very
Japanese the game by Final Fantasy dev
Squaresoft
took a few cues from Resident Evil and
introduced cop aya brea on a mission to
get rid of those very monsters from new
york city it also spawned two more
sequels of its own parasite eve - and
the third birthday
and finally we have Tom Clancy's Rainbow
six now the book and the game were
actually worked on at the same time and
they informed each other but the legacy
of the game still lives on to this day
the Rainbow six game spawned an entire
franchise made Tom Clancy a household
name in video games and basically wrote
the book on the tactical shooter and I
apologize my inability to avoid writing
cliches in any case Rainbow six made
gamers take their time to plan their
tactical approach to a mission before
actually going in and encouraged stealth
infiltrations in a way that was
basically unheard of in gaming so far
both the original game and the book
roughly followed the same plots where
the team must hunt down a terrorist unit
who want to release a mutated Ebola
virus at the Olympic Games
while our good guys end up on top either
way the video game was finished before
the book so the endgame plot does differ
let me know down in the comments which
game based on a novel is your favorite
and why also be sure to let me know if
there's any awesome games based on books
that I missed out on I'll catch you
again next week
you